hi I'm Marcus Phillips I'm the Dean and
co-founder of hack reactor an immersion
school for software engineering in San
Francisco we developed an outcome driven
and data-driven approach to education
called rapid iteration teaching I like
to think of myself as the educational
equivalent of Brad Pitt in Moneyball but
it may be more accurate to compare me to
Jonah Hill before founding hack reactor
I led technical training initiatives at
Twitter worked on their back-end
anti-spam systems and led the front-end
framework team I left Twitter at the end
of 2012 to start hack reactor and the
rest is history every second counts
during an immersive program and our team
has put a ton of thought into the
materials that you'll be seeing here
this course covers the first four days
of hack reactors 12 week curriculum so
you'll be getting a taste of the hyper
fast learning that leads our students to
a ninety nine percent placement rate I
consider these lessons the most
important fundamental material you can
have under your belt before moving
towards employment in any JavaScript
stack so whether you're new to
JavaScript programming or you've already
found it confusing for years together
we're going to find out just how clear
and easy it can be when you approach it
the right way